- Le bruit des bottes
résonne de plus en plus fort
à la frontière entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine, cette liiiii
pourrait être franchie par
les troupes de Vladimir Poutine
à n'importe quel moment.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier miniCaCaCaCaCanada
- Oui, nous craignons un conflit
armé en Ukraine. Nous sommes
extrêmement préoccupés
par le positionnement
du genenenenent russe.
- Le Canada, qui a dépêché plus
tôt cette semaine sa ministre
des Affaires étrangères
à Kiev, ne cesse de réitérer
son soutien à l'Ukraine.
- Nous allons continuer
d'être là en tant qu'allié
et partenaire de l'U
- Mais au-delà des 200 soldats
canadiens qui entraînent
des troupes sur place,
il faut, dit Kiev, des armes
et de l'équipement militaire.
Pour l'instant, Justin Trudeau
refuse de s'avancer.
Rappelant qu'un envoi
du genre pourrait davantage
provoquer la Russie.
Les États-Unis, eux,
n'hésitent pas à promettre
plus d'équipement à l'Ukraine
pour l'aider à se défendre.
Surtout, explique le secrétaire
d'État en visite à Kiev,
si la Russie va bel et bien
de l'avant avec une incursion.
PIERRE PAUL-HUS, député, PCC
Charlesbourg-Haute-St-Charles Qc
- On dirait que le gouvernement
libéral ne veut pas se commettre
plus fort que ça. On dirait
que le gouvernement, encore
une fois, attend de voir ce que
les autres pays vont faire.
- Mais si les conservateurs
critiquent la mollesse
du gouvernement Trudeau,
d'autres doutent que la solution
passe par l'envoi d'armes.
STÉPHANE BERGERON
député du Bloc québécois
- Je ne pense pas que ça fasse
frissonner les Russes dans
leurs bottes que de savoir
que des armes canadiennes
seraient vendues à l'Ukraine.
- Le Canada doit mettre
l'accent sur la diplomatie,
croit cet expert.
JUSTIN MASSIE, professeur
de sciences politiques UQAM
- Il faut tenter de voir
qu'est-ce que l'Ukraine est
prête à céder aux Russes
pour empêcher une incursion
militaire très probable
sur son territoire.
- Et c'est là où certains
experts pensent que le Canada
pourrait jouer un rôle plus
actif, étant donné ses liens
historiques avec l'Ukraine.
Mais il reste que, dans
les négociations avec Moscou,
le poids lourd demeure
Washington. Une rencontre
au sommet est d'ailleurs prévue
vendredi à Genève entre
le secrétaire d'État américain
et son homologue russe.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw